southbound interstate 15
finally opened tuesday morning after
a fatal crash monday night
how are you greetings cristian caceres
four people are reported to have died
in this crash police said a
woman was driving the wrong way and
collided with a  pick-up truck
because of this four more vehicles
were involved the authorities
believe that the woman was possibly driving
under the influence of toxic substances
discount that the police are following the
tracks of two men who unleashed a
shooting inside a guy in north las
vegas  An employee was shot and
taken to the hospital.
This incident occurred at the branch
located at Crazy Morning Tracking. The
suspects managed to flee the scene
in a silver Ford Taurus with
California license plates. If you are on your way
to Terminal 1 of
Henry International Airport.  reeve you might
face some delays i heard
this tuesday morning work  The dores have
started installing 300
security posts for added protection in this
area
this 4.9 million dollar project
is expected to be completed early
next year and we continue with
pleasant temperatures for the second week of
the new year we will have a day that is quite
sunny the highs  it will be at 61
degrees the temperatures will rise a bit
for Wednesday I am cristian cásseres
with his brief informative of iris known
Spanish good day
[Music]